le 12 janvier 1978 Marcel base couleur
est assassiné à asnières-les-bourges
étranglée par un marginal de 23 ans dans
le terrain vague où il habitait les
commerçants du centre-ville choqués par
sa mort décide de prendre en charge les
obsèques et la concession cimetière
Saint-Lazare de l'artiste des rues de
Bourges
[Musique]
mais qui était Marcel bascoulard
saltimbanque marginale ou artiste les
deux personnages principaux de Bourges
c'est quand même Jacques cœur le
milliardaire banquier et basculard le
miséreux le Diogène de Bourges
Diogène de Bourges mais surtout un
créateur
mais il avait un don de la couleur
extraordinaire qu'il a dû abandonner un
moment et un autre peut-être faute de
matériel de peinture tout simplement et
on connaît plus sa période
ancrée à l'encre il avait une maîtrise
pour restituer les volumes les
ombres c'était magnifique il immortalise
bon nombre de rues et de monuments du
cœur de Bourges notamment la cathédrale
Saint-Étienne des œuvres qui sont très
majoritairement des dessins de paysages
à la plume qu'ils vont ou échange avec
un objectif rester libre
il est évident que
j'ai toujours eu comme lettre motif de
mon existence le plaisir vésuel
et ce plaisir visuel a été servi par ce
tempérament d'indépendance dont je ne
suis je ne suis jamais de parti alors ce
qui m'a insisté toujours d'être seul
pour m'y observer puis alors mieux
penser
artiste mais aussi personnage de Bourges
il ne laisse pas indifférent en fait
bascula et quelqu'un qui qui adore se
mettre en scène il se fait prendre en
photo mais très jeune et à chaque fois
il pose notamment par exemple cette
photo là qui est on a l'impression que
c'est un acteur
c'est plus bide de
s'habiller en femme
présent aussi dans des ventes aux
enchères
45 ans après sa mort on voit encore
Marcel bascoulard dans la cité
Berruyères